gençler Merhaba bugünkü dersimizde
beraber
ısı ve sıcaklık ünitesine başlıyoruz
yani ÖSYM'nin favorilerinden her sene
banko bir tane soru koyduğu konularından
konu kavramsal bir konu bir sürü kavram
içeriyor bu kavramların bazıları kavram
yanılgıları içeriyor bunları çok iyi
öğrenmemiz gerekiyor simülasyon
deneyerken hepsini halledeceğiz Merak
etmeyin ısı sıcaklık ve iç enerji
kavramları ile başlayalım en başta
öğrenmemiz gereken 3 tane kavram var iç
enerji ısı ve sıcaklık kavramları bu
kavramların ne olduğunu birbirleriyle
ilişkisini birbirlerinden farkını iyi
öğrenmeniz gerekiyor ÖSYM 2 defa 3 defa
bunları sordu direkt koca ünite de
sadece buraya odaklandı ısıyla sıcaklığı
zaten günlük hayattan az buçuk
biliyorsunuzdur Ama çoğu onları da
yanlış biliyor birbiri yerine kullanıyor
yanlış kullanıyor ama hiç duymadığınız
Muhtemelen iç enerji kavramıyla
başlıyoruz iç enerji dediğimiz şey bir
Maddeyi oluşturan atom ve moleküllerin
titreşim dönme öteleme kinetik
enerjileri ile bu tanecikleri arasındaki
potansiyel enerjinin toplamıdır bir kere
kafadan şunu söyleyeyim Bu ünitede olan
biten her şey atomik moleküler boyutta
gerçekleşiyor gözümüzün göremediği o
milyon milyonlarca Molekülün halt etmesi
Bütün bunlar Dolayısıyla iç enerji
tanımını yaparken o moleküllerin
atomların kinetik Enerjileri aklınıza
gelmeli potansiyel Enerjileri aklınıza
gelmeli kinetik enerji önceki ünitemize
de öğrendiğimiz gibi hıza sahip olan
cisimlerin sahip olduğu enerjidir bu
atom ve moleküller yani tanecikler
titreşim hareketi yaparlar öteleme
hareketi yaparlar bir yerden bir yere
giderler dönme hareketi yaparlar
Bunların hepsi hız demek Dolayısıyla
kinetik enerji demek bir de potansiyel
enerji ifadesini görüyoruz ama bu
potansiyel enerjiyi görünce Aa hocam MS
Yerçekimi potansiyel enerjisi mi Hayır
değil parantez içinde de yazdığı gibi
bunlar bağ enerjisidir yani o
molekülleri birbirine bağlayan bağlarda
depolanmış enerjidir Örneğin su H2O
molekülü hidrojen atomlarıyla oksijen
atom arasındaki bağlarda depolanmış
enerji potansiyel enerji İşte bu
kinetikartı potansiyele biz iç enerji
diyoruz hocam Kentkart potansiyel
mekanik enerji değil miydi ya şu an
termodinamik ünitesindeyiz fiziğin alt
dalı değişti mekanikte değiliz
termodinamikdeyiz Evet benzer
kavramlarımız var kinetik enerji hala
kinetik enerji Ama buradaki potansiyel
enerji dediğim gibi esneklik potansiyel
ya da kütle çekim potansiyel değil
kimyasal bir enerji olan Bağ enerjisi
bahsettiğim Bağlar İşte buradaki azot
atomları arasında oksijen atomları
arasında karbondioksit molekülünün
arasında H2O su moleküllerinin arasında
bulunan bağ enerjisinden bahsediyoruz
tanecikler üzerinde iş yapıldığında ya
da sisteme enerji aktarıldığında iç
enerji artar Bakın bu ifadeyi sakın
unutmayın daha yakın zamandaki ÖSYM
sınavlarında çıktı bu Örneğin Bir
maddeyi ısıttığınızda o sisteme bir
enerji aktarmış oluyorsunuz Bu da iç
enerji arttırıyor ya da tanecikler
üzerine iş yaptığınızda dışarıdan bir
şekilde enerji verdiğinizde birazdan
deney videosunu izleyeceğiz iç enerjiyi
arttırıyorsunuz iç Enerjinin artması
demek kinetik artı potansiyelin artması
demek ya bir tanesi artıyordur ya da
ikisi birden artıyordur ama toplama
artacak Şimdi gelelim ikinci kavramımıza
yani sıcaklık kavramımıza sıcaklık
Maddeyi oluşturan atom ve moleküllerin
ortalama kinetik enerjilerinin bir
ölçüsüdür bakın ortalama kinetik
enerjisidir demedim Onun bir ölçüsü yani
ortalama kinetik enerjiye bakarak
sıcaklık hakkında fikir sah uyguluyoruz
Dolayısıyla bu uyarımdan sonra
diyebiliriz ki sıcaklık bir enerji
çeşidi değildir sıcaklık enerjisi diye
bir şey yok sıcaklık sadece bir gösterge
şuna benziyor ben bu kalemin boyunu
ölçüyorum bunun boyunu ölçmek için bir
cetvel kullanıyorum cetveli Bunun yanına
dayadım oradaki sayılara bakıyorum
alttaki ucu cetvelde sıfıra karşılık
geliyor üstteki ucu cetvelde Ona
karşılık geliyor diyorum ki A bu 10
santimetre uzunluğundaymış şimdi gerçek
anlamda bu kalemin boyu o cetveldeki
sayılar mı yani oradaki on sembolü bunun
boyu mu eş değer mi Bunlar Hayır o bir
gösterge bazı rakamlar kullandım Ve
bunun boyu hakkında yorum yaptım dedim
ki 10 cm o cetvel bir araçtı onun
üzerindeki sayılar bir göstergeydi
sıcaklıkta buna benziyor Ben kinetik
enerjiye bakıyorum tanecikler çok
hızlılarsa bu kinetik enerji fazla
oluyor diyorum ki burada çok kinetik
enerji var Aa O zaman bu madde sıcak
diyorum Burada az kinetik enerji var
tanecikler yavaş hareket ediyor diyorum
o zaman bu soğuk bir madde diyor
sıcaklığı te sembolüyle gösteriyoruz sa
birim sisteminde birimi Kelvin selsiyus
değil günlük hayatta çokça celsius
kullanıyoruz Bugün hava kaç dediğimizde
28 derece 28 celsi istiyoruz ama bu
saideki bir birim kullanımı değildir
vesairde Calvin birimi kullanılır bu
önemli fizik bilimine girişte de
vurgulamıştık ve biz bu sıcaklık
büyüklüğünü termometre ile ölçüyoruz
herhalde skaler büyüklük olduğunu da
vurgulamama gerek yok Termo zaten Eski
Yunancada sıcaklık ısı gibi anlamlara
geliyor zaten bir yerde metre kelimesini
görüyorsanız orada bir ölçü aleti
anlatılıyor demektir Dolayısıyla
sıcaklık ölçer gibi Türkçe'ye
çevirebilirsiniz tekrar vurguluyorum
sıcaklık bir enerji çeşidi değil Şimdi
sıcaklıkla ilgili bir simülasyon
izleyelim burada kapalı bir kabımız var
bunun üstüne bir termometre yani
sıcaklık ölçer yerleştirilmiş Kelvin
cinsinden ölçüm yapıyor ama istersek
celsius'a seçebiliriz bu gaz tanecikleri
ile ilgili bir simülasyon bunun
içerisine pompayla gaz taneciklerini
gönderiyorum gaz tanecikleri şu an
hareket halindeler katı sıvı gazı Hayal
ettiğimizde katı atomlarının çok sıkı
bitişik yanyana rahat hareket
edemediğini biliyoruz sıvılarda Bunlar
biraz daha ferahlar serbestler biraz
daha yayılmışlar gazlarda ise birbirleri
arasındaki bağlantı çok kopmuştur
atomların istedikleri gibi hareket
ederler İşte gördüğünüz gibi kabı
doldurdular zaten madde ve
özelliklerinde de konuşmuştuk gazlar
bulundukları kabın hacmini alırlar işte
her yeri doldurdular bulunduğu kabın
hacmini aldı Şimdi bizim işimiz bunlar
değil biz sıcaklıkla ilgileniyoruz
sıcaklık taneciklerin ortalama kinetik
enerjisinin bir ölçüsü burada
taneciklerin hareket ettiğini
görüyorsunuz yani hepsinin bir kinetik
enerjisi var niye ortalama diye
bahsediyoruz Çünkü Hepsi farklı hıza
sahip Dolayısıyla farklı kinetik
enerjiye sahip Biz ortalamaya bakıp
sıcaklık hakkında yorum yapıyoruz şu an
sıcaklık 300 kelvin'miş yani 27
celsius'muş ben alttan Bu kabı
ısıttığımda sıcaklığın gitti de
arttığını görüyorsunuz 150-160 200 diye
gidiyor patlamadan Ben bunu durduracağım
durdurdum şu anki taneciklerin
hareketini hızına odaklanın Bir de en
baştakine odaklanın şu an sıcaklığı çok
arttırdım Çünkü ben bu kabı ısıttım ona
bir enerji aktardım Bu aktardığım enerji
tanecikleri hızlandırdı kinetik
enerjilerini arttırdı O yüzden sıcaklık
arttı diyoruz Daha da soğutursam o zaman
bunların hızları Dolayısıyla kinetik
enerjilerini azalması lazım yani
sıcaklıklarını azalması lazım
soğutuyorum 400'ler 300'ler 200'ler
iyice soğutuyoruz gördüğünüz gibi
tanecikler gitgide yavaşlıyorlar
ortalama Kinetik enerjinin azaldığını
söyleyebilirim Hatta Evrende bir alt
sınır var Birazdan konuşacağız -273
celcius gibi bir değer o oraya
geldiğimizde artık hareket yoktur bile
diyebiliriz oraya indikçe de zaten
sıcaklık düşüşü yavaşladı Çünkü o bir
sınır onun daha fazla altına inemiyoruz
gördüğünüz gibi şu an -265 66 diye
soğuyor hız inanılmaz azaldı kinetik
enerji azaldı sıcaklık azaldı Sıcaklığı
da anladığımıza göre üçüncü kavramımız
ısı kavramımız
ısı için kafadan bir anahtar kelime
ısı transfer edilen enerjidir
sıcaklıkları farklı birbiriyle etkileşen
iki tane maddeyi yan yana getirdiğimizde
sıcak olandan soğuk olana doğru transfer
edilen enerjidir Isı enerjisi çay
doldurduğunuz bardağınıza geldiğiniz
odaya koydunuz çayınız 90 selfi Usta o
da 25 celsi Usta Eğer çayınızı içmeyi
unutursanız böyle yarım saat beklerseniz
çayınızın soğuduğunu görürsünüz Çünkü
sıcak olan çay soğuk olan
ısı transfer etmiştir Bu yüzden
soğumuştur ısı transfer edilir sahip
olunan bir şey değildir Bu söylediğim
şey de ÖSYM tarafından defalarca soruldu
Bir cismin içerisindeki ısı miktarı ya
da bir cismin ısısı ifadeleri doğru
değil ısıya sahip olamazsınız koca bir
kazan Kaynamış su hayal edin hem su
miktarı çok hem de kaynamış sıcaklığı
çok hocam bunun ısısı çoktur O zaman
yanlış ısısı sahip olunabilen bir şey
değildir
ısı transfer edilir Peki sahip olunan
şey ne ilk konuştuğumuz şey iç enerji iç
enerjiye sahip oluruz o kazanla ilgili
onun iç enerjisi çoktur diyebiliriz
ısısı çoktur diyemeyiz ısıyı q
sembolüyle gösteriyoruz birimi jul Çünkü
bu arkadaş bir enerji fakat biz bu
ünitede başka bir enerji birimi olan
kaloriyi kullanacağız kalori ifadesi
daha önce iş güç enerjide de geçmişti
canlılar ve enerji kısmında bu
şişmanlamak zayıflamak kısımlarında
anlatmıştım besinlerin sahip olduğu
enerji olarak kalori kullanıyoruz ve biz
ısıyı ölçmüyoruz ısıyı hesaplıyoruz
neyle hesaplıyoruz kalorimetre kabı ile
hesaplıyoruz niye ölçmüyoruz da
hesaplıyoruz eğer kalorimetre kabının
mantığını öğrenirseniz niye buna ölçme
değil de hesaplama denmesi gerektiğini
anlarsınız kalorimetre kabı bu Bunun
içerisinde su var termometre daldırılmış
Şurada da bir malzemeniz var bu
malzemeyi yakıyoruz işte burada
tutuşturma teli var falan filan Bunun
sayesinde bunu yakıyoruz bu yandığı
zaman etrafını Isı enerjisi veriyor ısı
enerji transfer ediyor ileride
öğreneceğimiz bir ifade var q m Delta t
m Bu maddenin kütlesi Bunu zaten
biliyoruz C Bu maddenin cinsi ile
alakalı türü ile alakalı ileride
öğreneceğimiz öz ısı kavramı bunu da
biliyoruz Termometrede bir Delta
okuyacağız Çünkü bu arkadaş Isı enerjisi
verdikçe etrafına bunu transfer ettikçe
bu suyu ısıtmış oluyor bu su ısındıkça
sıcaklığı artıyor ve bu termometre O
sıcaklığın ne kadar arttığını gösteriyor
yani bana bunu söylüyor Ben bunu
biliyorsam q'yu da biliyorumdur ne kadar
Isı enerjisi transfer edildiğini de
biliyorumdur Böylece bu ısı enerjisini
hesaplamış oluyorum
az önce de dediğim gibi Aslında
Isı enerjisinin birimi jul fakat biz
genelde kalori kullanacağız ünitede ve
böyle bir dönüşüm var ezbere bilmek
zorunda mısınız Tabii ki değilsiniz
şimdi ısıyı sıcaklığı ve iç enerjiyi
öğrendik dediğim gibi bu 3 kavramı çok
iyi bileceksiniz kavram yanılgılarına
düşmeyeceksiniz Az önce anlattığım
simülasyon üzerinden bu 3 kavramı bir
konuşalım az önce bu simülasyonda
sıcaklığı konuşmuştuk gaz tanecikleri
üzerinden konuşmuştuk Ben yine bu kapalı
kabın içerisine gaz taneciklerinin
pompaladım bunların şu an kinetik
Enerjileri var dolayısıyla bir sıcaklık
var değeri şu an 300 Kelvin Biz bunu
celcius olarak görürsek 27 selsiyus
olarak söyleyebiliriz şimdi zaten
sıcaklığı anladık ortalama Kinetik
enerjinin bir ölçüsü Ben bunu alttan
ısıttığımda sıcaklığı arttırıyorum Neden
Çünkü ben bu alttaki ocaktan buraya
içeriye
Isı enerjisi transfer ediyorum yani bu
kabın içerisine sistemi Isı enerjisi
aktarıldı içeriye Isı enerjisi
aktarıldığı için kabın içindeki Bu
maddenin iç enerjisi arttı bunu şöyle
düşünün bir fabrika düşünün bir depo
düşünün içinde mallar var işte oradaki
malların tümü sahip olduğum tüm mallar
iç enerjidir transfer edilen enerji olan
ısı O zaman bu de mal getiren tırlardır
ben alttan ocağa yaktığımda fabrikaya
yeni mallar geldi Yeni tırlar geldi
Dolayısıyla içerideki mal sayısı arttı
Yani iç enerji miktarı arttı ve iç
enerji dediğim şey de taneciklerin
kinetik enerjisi ile potansiyel
enerjisini toplamı olduğuna göre bu
toplam arttı sıcaklığın arttığını
gördüğüme göre bu toplam Kinetik
enerjinin artışına da yansımış kinetik
enerji arttığı için bu toplam arttı
diyebiliriz Burada hemen şu uyarıyı
yapayım Her iç enerji artışı kinetik
enerji artacak anlamına gelmez hal
değişimi diye bir konumuz var maddenin
iç enerjisi arttığı halde sıcaklığı
değişmeyecek orada da potansiyel enerji
artıyor diyeceğiz Bu ayrımlara dikkat
edelim Dolayısıyla benzetmemize geri
dönersek fabrika içindeki mallar hiç
enerji tırlar yani transfer eden araçlar
ısı sıcaklıktan nasıl bahsedebiliriz
sıcaklık bir göstergeydi Kinetik
enerjinin bir göstergesiydi O zaman
şöyle düşünsem içerde çok mal varsa iç
enerji çoktur Yüksek ihtimalle kinetik
enerjide çoktur mal çok olduğu için Bu
da adamın zenginliğini gösterir yani
Adamın zenginliği de sıcaklıktır bir
göstergedir asıl olan şey mallar bunun
göstergesi zenginlik yani sıcak demir
var tuğla var burada ocaklarımız var su
var zeytinyağı var
Isı enerjisi iç enerjisi kavramlarına
Bir de burada bakalım enerji
sembollerini göster dedim Böylece
malzemelerin iç enerjisini gösteren
küçük küçük kutucuklar görüyorsunuz
Demirde de var tuğla'da da var suda da
var zeytinyağı da da var termometre
sıcaklığımızı ölçer demirin sıcaklığını
tuğlanın sıcaklığını suyun ya da
zeytinyağını sıcaklığını Bununla
ölçeceğiz şimdi ben demiri ocağın üstüne
koydum Hatta tuğlayı da koyayım Hatta
ısıtıcılar birlikte çalışsın Şimdi ben
bunları ısıtıyorum ne görüyorsunuz
ocaktan demire ve tuğlaya enerji
aktarılıyor İşte bu aktarılanlar ısı
enerjisidir Isı enerjisi alan maddelerin
e'leri artıyor Yani iç Enerjileri
artıyor Hocam bu dışarıya çıkan e'ler ne
madde aynı zamanda da soğuyor aynı sizin
odada tek başına bekleyen çayınız gibi
alttan Isı enerjisi alıyoruz dışarıya da
yukarıdan Sen enerjisi veriyoruz gibi
düşünebilirsiniz bakın E kaybettikçe
yani dışarıya ısı enerjisi verdikçe
içerideki e miktarı azalıyor Yani iç
enerji azalıyor şimdi bunların
sıcaklıklarını ölçelim gördünüz mü
termometre tavan yaptı Çünkü belli ki
oradaki tanecikler daha hızlı hareket
ediyor Şimdi Suya koydum ben bunu su
daha soğuk termometre bunu küçük
gösteriyor aldım demiri suyun içine
attım bakın Termometrede yükselme
gördüğünüz yani suyun sıcaklığı arttı
Neden Çünkü sıcak olan demirden soğuk
olan suya Isı enerjisi aktarıldı yani
Demir soğudu taneciklerin kinetik
enerjisi azaldı su ısındı sıcaklığı
arttı taneciktenin hikayesi arttı
diyebiliriz
ısıca yalıtılmış bir ortamda şekildeki
gibi Özdeş X ve Y bardaklarını aynı anda
en ve iki M kütleli 90 celsi sıcaklıkta
çaydan konuyormuş Buna göre
yargılarından hangileri doğrudur
denilmiş Şimdi buradaki iki çay da 90
celsius sıcaklığa sahip yani sıcaklıklar
aynı o zaman kesinlikle Şunu
yapıştırabilirim her iki Çayda da
taneciklerin ortalama kinetik Enerjileri
aynıdır Çünkü sıcaklıklar aynı x
bardağındaki çayın taneciklerin ortalama
kinetik enerjisi y'den küçüktür Hayır
eşittir dedim şimdi y bardağındaki çayın
ısısı cümleye Devam etmiyorum çayın
ısısı diye bir şey olmaz bu bir kavram
yanılgısıdır Çünkü
ısı sahip olunabilen bir şey değil
transfer edilen şeydir sahip olunan şey
iç enerjidir X ve Y bardakları arasında
Isı alışverişi olmaz bu enerjisi
sıcaktan soğuğa aktarılır her zaman bu
sıcaklıklar eşitse o zaman herhangi bir
aktarım olmaz bunların sıcaklıklara eşit
mi Evet eşit bunları yan yana getir
birbirleriyle etkileşim halinde olsunlar
hiçbir Isı alışverişi olmaz bu öncülüm
doğrudur Peki ben burada iç enerji ile
de ilgili bir şey sorayım bunların iç
enerjilerini kıyaslasak y bardağının
ısısı içten büyük değil ama y bardağının
iç enerjisi içten büyük Nereden anladın
Ben onu iç enerji dediğim şey
taneciklerin kinetiyle potansiyelinin
toplamı Bunların kinetiği aynı ama
potansiyelleri aynı değil Nasıl Anladık
kütlelerden anladık en kütle var İki hem
kütle var buradaki tanecik sayısıyla
molekül sayısıyla buradaki aynı değil
sağdakinde daha fazla molekül var Bu da
daha fazla bağ demek daha fazla
potansiyel enerji demek hangisi
üzerinize dökülse daha çok yanarsınız
Tabii ki Sağdaki bunu içen enerjiden
düşünebilirsin böyle bir çağrışım
yaptırabilirsiniz zihninde iç enerjisi
fazla bana daha çok zarar verir gibi
düşünebiliriz ısıtıcı yaratılmış ortamda
k l ve M bardaklarına şekildeki gibi
belirtilen kütlelerde ve sıcaklıklarda
su konulmuş bardaklardaki iç
enerjilerini kıyaslayınız taneciklerin
kinetik artı potansiyeline bakacağız 60
celsius 60 celcius Bunların kinetikleri
aynı ama burada 100 gram su var burada
50 gram su var o zaman buradaki
potansiyel fazla buradaki potansiyel
enerji daha az kinetikler aynı
soldakinde potansiyel enerji fazla
olduğu için k'daki iç enerji lekinden
büyüktür diyebiliriz l ile m'yi
kıyaslayalım İkisi de 50 gram o zaman
buradaki potansiyel enerji ile buradaki
potansiyel enerjiye aynı diyebilirim
madde miktarları yani bağ sayıları aynı
olarak düşünebilirim maddenin türü de
aynı yani sadece bağ miktarına bakmak
yetmez o bağda depolanın enerjiye
bakmamız lazım o da maddenin türüne göre
değişir h2o'da farklıdır azot
moleküllerinde farklıdır ama hepsi su
olduğu için herhangi bir problemimiz yok
bu 60 celsius'da yani buradaki kinetik
daha büyük buradaki kinetik daha küçük
potansiyeller aynı kinetiği fazla olan L
olduğu için o zaman l'nin iç enerjisi de
m'den daha büyüktür diyebiliriz ya da
çağrışım yaptıralım hangisi üzerinize
dökülse Eyvah dersiniz Tabii ki bu
arkadaş en büyük için termometre
çeşitlerine girmeden önce iç enerji ile
ilgili enteresan bir durum olduğunu
söylemiştim onu da bir konuşalım
Isı enerjisi alan maddenin enerjisi
artar burada bir katı malzemenin kristal
yapıdaki bir katı malzemenin görünüşünü
görüyorsunuz buradaki mavi tanecikleri
atomlar olarak düşünebilirsiniz atomlar
bağlanmışlar işte kristal yapı halinde
bir malzememiz var şimdi ben bunu
ısıtacağım Yani bu malzemeye Isı
enerjisi transfer edeceğim ve iç
enerjisi artacak gördüğünüz gibi
tanecikler daha çok titremeye başladılar
yani kinetik enerjilerini arttırdılar Bu
da malzemenin sıcaklığının artması demek
malzemenin aynı zamanda iç enerjisinin
artması demektir diyebiliriz Peki sadece
ısı enerjisi aktararak mı hiç enerjiyi
arttırırız Az önce tanımda şöyle bir şey
demiştim tanecikler üzerine iş
yapıldığında da iç enerji artar Tamam bu
Senarist aktarıyoruz arttırıyoruz
taneciklerin üzerine iş yapmak ne demek
şimdi ben bu kristal yapının altına ve
üstüne Tabiri caizse böyle hidrolik bir
pres getirdim bunu Sıkıştıracağım bir
basınç uygulayacağım ona bir darbe
vuracağım şu anki taneciklerin
hareketine dikkat edin Bir de
sıkıştırdığında dikkat edin sıkıştırdım
gördüğünüz gibi çok fazla titreşim
sahibi oldular yani kinetik enerji arttı
Yani bu madde ısındı sıcaklığı arttı
Çünkü ben dışarıdan buna bastırarak
tanecikler üzerinde bir iş yaptım Önceki
ünitemizden hatırlayın bir cisim
üzerinde iş yapılırsa onun enerjisini
değiştirirsiniz işte iş yaptım
enerjisini değiştirdim Bu da bir iç
enerji artışıdır sadece ısı enerjisi ile
ilişkilendirmeyin hiç enerjiyi Hocam bu
bana çok saçma geldi yani biz Bir
maddeyi sıkıştırdık diye sıcaklığım
artıyor Evet deneyini izleteyim bakın Bu
videoda bir Demirci demire vuruyor aynı
benim simülasyonda izlettiğim gibi bir
malzemeyi sıkıştırıyor gibi
düşünebilirsiniz oradaki tanecikler
üzerinde iş yapıyor o sisteme bir enerji
aktarıyor İşte bu enerji aktarımı iç
enerjiyi arttırır Sıcaklığı da arttırır
gördüğünüz gibi ucu kızardı malzeme o
kadar ısındı ki şu an Işık yayıyor Aynı
bizim simülasyondaki gibi şu an bu
demirin tanecikleri daha hızlı hareket
ediyor sıcaklıktan devam ediyoruz
sıcaklık ölçen alet termometrelere
bakıyoruz Termo Eski Yunancada ısı
sıcaklık gibi anlamlara geliyor metre
ölçü aleti gibi bir anlamı var
Dolayısıyla sıcaklık ölçer Bunun
Türkçesi diyebiliriz Peki bu adam bir
malzemenin sıcak nasıl anlıyor Dolaylı
yoldan anlıyor fizikteki bazı
büyüklükleri kullanıyoruz mesela
genleşmeyi kullanıyoruz bizim çeşitli
termometrelerimiz var lise müfredatında
bilmen gereken metal termometreler yani
katılar sıvılı termometreler ve gazlı
termometreler birazdan detaylarını
Göreceğiz Ama ister metal termometre
olsun ister sıvılı termometre olsun
ister Gazi termometre olsun hepsinde
genleşmeyi kullanabiliyoruz nasıl bir
şey Peki bu genleşme şöyle diyelim ki
sizin şöyle metal bir çubuğunuz var Ben
henüz anlatmadım ama günlük hayattan
bilirsiniz genleşmek demek bir maddenin
sıcaklığı arttırıldığında yani ona Isı
enerjisi hacminin büyümesi demek boyunun
uzaması demek şimdi sizin elinizde böyle
bir metal var kolaylıkla genleşebilen
bir malzeme bununla şu yeşille
gösterdiğim abidik gubidik cismin
sıcaklığını ölçeceksiniz bu metalinizi
sıcaklığını ölçeceğiniz bu yeşil cisme
dokundurduğunuzda yakınına
getirdiğinizde aralarında sıcaklık farkı
varsa Isı alışverişi olur diyelim ki bu
sıcak bir malzeme Dolayısıyla sıcakla
soğuk yan yana geldiğinde sıcaktan
soğuğa doğru
Isı enerjisi aktarılacaktır yani sizin
metaliniz Isı enerjisi aldı Isı enerjisi
Aldığı için bu arkadaşın sıcaklığı arttı
ve boyu uzadı Yani genleşti bunun altına
da Bir ölçek yerleştirdiniz atıyorum
şurası artı 5'ti şurası artı 8'di şurası
artı 10'du şurası artı 12'ydi normalde
Sizin metaliniz artı Ona karşılık
geliyordu o sıcak maddeden ısı alınca
uzadı genleşti artı 12'ye karşılık geldi
ucu İşte buradaki bu sayılarda sıcaklığa
karşılık geliyor senin bu metal gösterge
12'de durduğunda diyorsun ki He bu yeşil
cismin sıcaklığı 12 celsius'muş şu an
tamamen kavramsal anlatıyorum yoksa bir
termometreyi açtığınızda böyle bir çubuk
yanında da gösterge görmüyorsunuz işin
mantığını anlatıyor gerçekten Bunlar
daha profesyonel ve daha Mühendislik
harikası Tabii ki bunun tersi de mümkün
ölçmek istediğiniz şey soğuk da olabilir
o zaman tersten düşünelim diyelim ki
sizin metal çubuğunuz Yani aslında
termometreniz normalde 10 seviyesinde
yani şu an termometreniz 10 derece gibi
soğuk malzemeye yaklaştırdınız bu artık
soğuk bir malzeme olsun bu sefer soğuk
Isı enerjisi alacak yani
termometrenizden bu temizlemeye ısısı
enerjisi aktarılacak sizin termometreniz
ısı verdi sıcaklığı azalır Sıcaklığı
azalan maddeler genleşmenin tam tersi
küçülür Bu arkadaşın şu ucu geriye gelir
atıyorum şuraya gelir artı 8'e gelir bu
ne anlama geldi artık bu yeşil maddenin
sıcaklığı artı 8 selsiyusmuş daha
soğukmuş genleşmenin mantığı katılarda
da böyledir sıvılarda da böyledir
gazlarda da böyledir renk değişimi ile
anlayabiliyoruz aynı mantığın renklere
göre düzenlenmişi var direnç değişimiyle
anlayabiliyoruz ki bu günlük hayatta
kullandığımız dijital termometrelerdir
Aslında böyle koltuğumuzun altına
koyarız elektronik bir göstergesi vardır
o koltuğumuzun altından çıkartıp
elektronik göstergede vücut
sıcaklığımızı ölçeriz direnç değişimi
ile çalışır yani elektronik bir sistem
termistör denilen bir alet var
elektronikte Ders kitabında bunun bahsi
geçiyor sıcaklığa bağlı olarak o
direncin değeri artıyor direnç değeri
artarsa devrede dolaşan elektrik akımı
azalır sistemde der ki Aa bak devredeki
elektrik akımı şu kadar düştü Demek ki
direnç bu kadar artmış direnci bu kadar
arttıran şey de şu kadar sıcaklıktır
diye ölçüm yapmış oluyoruz tamamen
elektronik ortamda bir ölçüm bu
Dolayısıyla dijital termometrelerin
çalışma mantığıdır sıvılarda genleşme
mantığıyla ölçüm yapıyoruz gazlarda
genleşme mantığı Bir de basınç değişimi
yoluyla yine ileride öğreneceğimiz
basınç konusunda pv nrt var Belki
kimyada öğrenmişsinizdir Şu Arkadaş
hacim sabit bu arkadaş gaz miktarı sabit
R zaten sabit sayı T sıcaklık demek p
basınç demek Sizin bir gazlı
termometreniz var içinde gaz var o gazın
basıncındaki değişikliklere bakarak
sıcaklığı hakkında fikir sahibi
oluyorsunuz Örneğin Gazi termometrenizi
sıcak bir cisme yaklaştırıyorsunuz sıcak
cisme yaklaştırdığınız için gazlı
termometrenizin içindeki gaz ısınıyor
sıcaklığı artıyor sıcaklığı arttığı için
basıncı artıyor basınç sensörlerini
okuyarak o sıcaklık hakkında fikir
sahibi oluyorsunuz yani termometrenizin
basınç sensörü Normalde atıyorum p'yi
gösteriyor Bu iki p'ye çıktığında Sen
anlıyorsun ki ha sıcaklık t'den 2t
yükselmiş ölçümü böyle yapıyorsun şimdi
bu termometrelere detaylı bakacağız
Öncelikle sıvılı termometreden
başlıyoruz az önce konuştuk genleşme
prensibi'ne göre çalışıyor şu şekli az
bu aşinasınızdır evlerde odalarda Hatta
benim çocukluğumda Ateş ölçerken Biz
sıvılı termometre kullanırdık Bunların
içinde cıva olabilirdi alkol olabilirdi
bunlar günlük hayat sıcaklıklarını
ölçerlerdi o yüzden odaya bundan asardık
işte 20 celcius 25 celsi 30 celsius gibi
sıcaklıkları ölçerdi Bunlar genelde neye
göre cıva kullanılıyor neye göre alkol
kullanılıyor Tabii ki çalışabilme
özelliklerine göre cıva dediğiniz şey
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam eksi 30
selsiyuslarda donuyor alkol dediğim
şeyse -120 celsius'larda falan donuyor
Şimdi ben cıvalı termometreyi Kars'ta
kullanamam Şubat ayında gece hava
sıcaklığı -35 olduğunda civa döner donan
civa benim işime yaramaz hiç bir ölçüm
yapamaz dolayısıyla çok soğuk
memleketlerde alkollü termometre
kullanılır Peki biz bunlarla istediğimiz
yüksek sıcaklığı ölçebilir miyiz niye
günlük hayat diye vurgulanmış Bunların
bir de üst limiti de var alkol dediğin
sıvı 78 celsius'ta kaynıyor civa yine
300 celsiuslara falan çıkabiliyor Ama
özellikle alkol 78'de kaynıyor kaynayan
sıvı nasıl genleşsin nasıl doğru ölçüm
yapalım O yüzden ne kadar
sıcaklıklarıyla sınırlı bu genleşme
mantığını şöyle anlayabiliriz bakın
burada boyanmış bir sıvımız var
kolaylıkla genleşebilen bir sıvı bu
bizim termometre modelimiz olacak
Buradaki sıvı sıcaklığı artarsa yükselen
sıcaklığı azalırsa soğuyan bir sıvı Şu
an onu sıcak bir su dolu kaba koyuyor ve
sıvı seviyesine dikkat edin sıvı
seviyesi yükseliyor Çünkü bizim
termometremizin sıcaklığı artıyor sıvı
genleşiyor işte sen bunun karşısında
Şuraya bir ölçek çizersen bu sıvı
seviyesinin Durduğu yere sayılar
yazarsan mesela 80 selsiyus yazarsan
şuraya 90 celsius yazarsan Bu sıvı
seviyesi nerede durursa sıcaklıkta o
olmuş olur Termometrenin temel mantığı
budur gördüğünüz gibi hala yükseliyor
Çünkü sıvımız genleşiyor çünkü sıcaklığı
artıyor diyebiliriz o sıcak suyun
sıcaklığını ölçüyor şu anda yanda buz
dolu bir kap var şimdi bu termometreyi
buz dolu kaba koyuyor yani şu an Ben
oradaki buzun sıcaklığını ölçmeye
çalışıyorum Bu sefer soğuk olan şey bu
soğuk bir şey ölçmeye çalışıyoruz Bizim
termometremiz Isı kaybedecek buza soğuk
olanı ısı transfer edecek ısı kaybettiği
için sıcaklığı azalacak sıcaklığı
azaldığı için bu sefer genleşmeyecek
büzülecek yani küçülecek buradaki sıvı
seviyesinin azaldığını göreceğiz bu
azalma az öncekine göre daha yavaş
oluyor çok beklememiz gerekebilir Evet
biraz daha aşağıda olduğunu şu an daha
net görüyoruz yeterince beklersek bunun
daha da aşağıya indiğini görürüz güzel
bir termometre tasarlamak için hassas
ölçüm yapan bir termometre tasarlamak
için bizim bu cam borumuzun genleşme
katsayısı Az Olmalı yani o cam
genleşmemeli içindeki sıvı genleşecek
Çünkü cam da genleşirse o zaman sıvı mı
yükselemez Düşünsene Senin o borun
genişliyor E o zaman sıvı yükselemez ki
o yüzden bizim borumuz mümkün olduğu
kadar ince olmalı kesit alanı küçük
olmalı ki sıvı kolaylıkla yükselebilsin
genleşememeli bizim camımız dışarıdaki
kap genleşmemeli sıvı genleşmeli sıvının
genleşme katsayısı çok olmalı Şuradaki
sıvı hazinesi büyük olmalı Çünkü orada
ne kadar çok sıvı varsa o kadar çok
genleşecektir iyi yükselecektir veya iyi
alçalayacaktır Böylece Biz de düzgün bir
ölçüm yapabileceğiz ve son olarak da
sıcaklık aralığının ölçeklendirilme
miktarı şöyle şimdi bu modele dikkat
edersek kenarındaki çizgiler kaç derece
sıcaklık olduğunu celsius cinsinden
söylüyor sağ tarafta şu an ölçüm işte
22'ye falan karşılık geliyor şimdi şu
aradaki kısa çizgiler olmasaydı Bizim
sayılarımız -40 eksi 30 - 20 yani burada
bir çizgi var burada bir çizgi var
burada bir çizgi var aralarda hiçbir şey
yok o kısa çizgiler Yok daha kötü bir
ölçüm yaparım Benim buradaki sıvı
seviyem geldi şurada durdu sen buraya 10
yazmışsın buraya 20 yazmışsın E biz
Arada Bir yerdeyiz o kaça geliyor
bilmiyorum ki oraya ölçek koymadık işte
ne kadar sık aralıklı çizgilerin olursa
küsüratları da ölçersin dersin ki Aa bak
burası 17'ye karşılık geliyor dersin
onunla 20 arasında bir yer demezsin yani
ölçeklendirmede hassas bir termometre
için önemlidir metal termometrelere
geldiğimizde bunların anahtar kelimesi
bunlar yüksek sıcaklık ölçerler içinde
sıvı yok genleşme mantığını anlatırken
kullandığım o metal aklınıza gelsin
metalin uzaması kısalmasına göre
buradaki ibre çıkıyor ve Aşağı iniyor
sen de oradan kaç selsiyus olduğunu
okuyorsun Bunlar genelde endüstride
fırınlarda fabrikalarda kullanılıyor
mesela Demir eritiyorsun demir döküm
fabrikası bir demirin erime sıcaklığı
1530 selsiyus falan Şimdi ben 1530
celcius hangi termometre ile ölçeceğim
civalı termometre ile mi ölçeyim adam
300'de kaynıyor zaten o kaynamasa bile
Zaten cam kırılır o Yüksek sıcaklıkta
İşte bu sıcaklıklara Ancak bir metal
termometre dayanabilir gazlı termometre
deyince de aklınıza hassas ölçüm gelsin
Öncelikle Çünkü yine genleşme üzerinden
düşünürsem en iyi genleşen maddeler
gazlardır sonra sıvılardır en kötü
genleşen maddelerde katılardır gazlar
çok iyi genleşebiliyorlar çünkü
taneciklerin arası çok uzak olduğu için
Sen bunu ısıttığında daha da kolay
uzaklaşabiliyorlar birbirlerinden ama
katı tanecikleri Birbirine çok yakın
Bunlar çok yakın oldukları için Isı
enerjisi verdiğinde hareketlendiler
birbirlerinden uzaklaşacaklar ama aynı
zamanda birbirlerini de çekiyorlar çok
iyi uzaklaşamıyorlar ama gazlar zaten
kendi başına hepsi bir yerde bir de ısı
veriyorsun kinetik iyice artıyor iyice
uzaklaşıyorlar Tabii ki istisnalar var
bazı sıvılardan daha iyi genleşen
katılar var ama biz genel konuşuyoruz
iyi genleştiği için bunlar hassas ölçüm
yaparlar Çünkü kolay tepki verirler
sıcaklık değişimlerine Bu yüzden bu
arkadaşlar genelde laboratuvarlarda
kullanılırlar bir şey daha var burada
bahsedilmesi gereken gazlı
termometrelerle aynı zamanda çok
soğukların ölçümünü yaparız mesela -200
selsiyus sıcaklığındaki Bir maddeyi
gazlı termometre ile rahatlıkla
ölçebiliriz sıvılı termometre işine
yaramaz Çünkü sıvılı termometre zaten en
babası alkollü termometre eksi %10'da
donuyor donmuş termometre ile ölçüm
yapamaz ama bazı gazlar çok düşük
sıcaklıklara inebiliyorlar gaz halinde
sıvılaşmadan Örneğin helyum bir gaz
biliyorsunuz En azından Oda şartlarında
eksi 269 selsiyus'ta sıvı hale geçip
sıvı helyum oluyor yani Sen helyumdan
bir termometre tasarlasan sıvı hale
geçene kadar gaz fazında -269'a kadar
ölçüm yapabilirsin Bu yüzden bu
termometrelerle Biz çok soğuk maddeleri
de ölçebiliyoruz Gazi termometre aşağıya
yukarı şöyle bir şeye benziyor ve tekrar
Çok düşük sıcaklıkları ölçebildiğini de
burada vurgulamış olalım Şimdi gelelim
Hocam bu anlattıklarınızı ben hiç
etrafımda görmüyorum sıvılı termometre
falan Çocukken bir iki kere görmüştüm
ama biz genelde şunları görüyoruz
diyebilirsiniz gayet haklı olarak
özellikle pandemi döneminde herkesin
ateşinin ölçüldüğü dönemde şu soldaki
arkadaş bol bol hayatımızın içindeydi bu
termistörle çalışan dersin başında
anlattığım dijital termometre işte
dirençteki değişim üzerinden ölçüm
yapıyor direncin sıcaklığı arttığında
direnç değeri artıyor devrede dolaşan
elektrik akımı azalıyor o devrede
dolaşan akımın azalma miktarı bize
sıcaklık olarak bu göstergede gözüküyor
yani akıma bakarak sıcaklığı söylüyor
gibi bir yorum yapabiliriz şimdi bu
dijital termometreydi termistörlüydü
soldakine de prometri deniyor aklınıza
gelen piroyla hiçbir alakası yok Bu
elektromanyetik dalgalarla çalışıyor
vücudumuzdan kızılötesi dalgalar
yayınlanır kumandaya bastığınızda kanal
değiştiriyorsunuz ya kumanda ile
televizyon arasındaki iletişimi Kuran
şey de aynı kızılötesi dalgalar insan
vücudu da bu dalgalardan yayar bu
dalgaları algılıyor bu arkadaş
elektromanyetik dalganın kızılötesi
dalganın şiddetine göre göstergesinde
bir sıcaklık ölçüyor O yüzden bunun
vücudunuza değmesine bile gerek yok
Böyle uzaktan tabanca tutar gibi
alnımıza ölçüm yaptılar pandemi
döneminde Çünkü o kızılötesi dalgayı
algılamak için vücuduma temas etmesine
gerek yok evet kazanım uygulama üçe
bakalım tabloda verilen sıcaklık
değerlerinin ölçümünde kullanılması en
uygun olan termometre türünü yazınız -70
selsiyus 160 selsiyus 25 celsius 25
celsius günlük hayat ve sıvılı
termometre duvara astığımız termometre
İşte bunlar civalı veya alkollü 160
selsiyus nispeten yüksek bir sıcaklık
bütün türleri yazmaya çalıştığım için
buna metal termometre diyebilirim cıvalı
termometre de ölçemez mi hocam o da
300'de falan kaynıyor demiştiniz yani
kaynayana kadar ölçüm yapabilir
yapabilir ama dediğim gibi Genelde bu
sıvılılar mesela cıvalı termometre
günlük hayata göre ayarlandığı için
onların o cam borularının üzerinde 160'a
kadar çıkmaz en fazla 50'ye 60'a kadar
değer görürsünüz o yüzden buna metal
yazmamıza herhangi bir sakınca yok -70
soğuk ölçüyoruz Soğuk olduğunda
başvuracağımız termometre gazlı
termometre olacaktır hocam alkollü
termometre olmaz moda eksi 118 falan
demiştiniz o da olur Ama ben hepsini
yazmak istedim o yüzden çok kafa
karıştırmaya gerek yok sıvılı
termometrelerle ilgili hangileri
doğrudur sıvının bulunduğu kılcal
Borunun genleşme katsayısı sıvıdan büyük
olmalıdır Hayır sıvının bulunduğu bu
boru genleşmemeli olduğu gibi kalmalı
içindeki genleşebilmeli az önce de
söylediğim gibi bu boru da büyürse o
zaman sıvının yükselmesi zorlaşır doğru
ölçüm yapamam sıvının donma noktasının
ve kaynama noktasının arasındaki
sıcaklıkları ölçebilir Evet alkollü
termometre eksi 110'la artı 78 arasını
ölçebilir Bunun dışında sıvı olmayacağı
için ölçüm yapamaz kılcal boru ne kadar
sık bölmelendirilirse sıvı o kadar iyi
genleşir olta bir Öncül bu hoca dedi ki
daha sık bölmelendirme daha iyi ölçüm
zaten ölçüm de genleşme ile oluyor o
zaman üçüncü öncülüğüm doğru Hayır
yanlış sıvının genleşme özelliği kendine
has içine koyduğum Borunun üzerindeki
çizgileri sıklaştırdın diye o sıvı daha
iyi genleşmez ya da daha kötü genleşmez
Sadece bu sık bölmelendirme Bizim daha
hassas okuma yapmamızı sağlıyor okuma
duyarlılığımızı arttırıyor sen oradaki
sayılara ne yazarsan yaz ne kadar çizgi
koyarsan koy senin sıvı dediğin şey şu
seviyeden şu seviyeye çıkar karşısına ne
koyduğun hangi çizgiyi koydun kaç
yazdığının Hiçbir önemi yoktur
Dolayısıyla 3 öncülüm yanlış Sorumun
cevabı yanlış 2 olmalıdır Evet sıcaklık
ölçeklerine geldik ama bunu bir sonraki
derse bırakacağım Bu ders bu kadar da
takıldıklarınızı alta yazın Kendinize
iyi bakın görüşürüz
[Müzik]